to see you I like a man who comes in
double fisting already
oh no it's triple dope all this yeah you
hold it is too heavy for me yeah look at
that what a night for you do you wrap
your brain around having three Oscars in
your hand at one time not yet no no not
yet nothing caught them here you know
people were wondering what this show
would be like because for the first time
since 89 there wasn't going to be a host
I thought especially Tina Amy and Maya
were amazing they were amazing amazing
amazing I wish they will present it I
did too I wish that they would have just
hosted Germany they kind of did hopes
the show because they came an open know
yes because that best thing of the show
had started with an amazing energy first
with Queen and then with with with it
with this amazing through you and then
he cannot kind of set the tone of the
whole thing was it was wonderful and you
took home three trophies for a movie
that speaks to your heart in a very
personal way what do you lose that means
very surprising yes I mean this is not
in paper is not your traditional Oscar
payn
and this was the last thing that we
thought it was going to happen while we
were doing it when we finish it and and
and the fact that he's been recognized
like that it's only a testament to the
elites up at issue
you know because this character is a
domestic worker from a new genus
background it's been embraced by
audiences all around the world and if
Roma works is because of the elites well
now you see is KB I think apparently is
the base but it's heavy and they this is
Kahlo
[Music]
[Applause]